you are all Hypocrites you all do it
Michael
confession
I have done PDA in the office thank you
I've had intercourse in the office all
right as has Angela Dwight as has Ryan
as as Kelly as has Meredith as has
Phyllis as has Daryl as has Creed as has
Michael and as has Holly as has Kevin
with who she goes to another school okay
fine no more PDA good okay you win but
here's what we are gonna do we're going
to designate one of our closets as a
hookup Zone anything goes just leave it
Michael that's absurd what if two
couples want to go at the same time
no no we're gonna have three closets one
for each base no homers yes and what is
the hookup Zone policy on masturbation
Pro yes what no no it's great I love
working at Dunder Mifflin a division of
Taliban Enterprises
that's weird
I mean that's weird
to have sex in the office that's where
you work right
[Music]
you're in a meeting and nobody knows
that you've had sex there except for you
and him
ew
ah hey hey no time to chat well we were
just looking for Ryan so he's not here
hey you looking for me oh yeah we were
we were just gonna say hi so hey
no you weren't no we weren't you wanted
to have sex in my office nope definitely
not it's it's it's cool just um try to
put everything back where you found it
uh text me when you're finished up I'll
be out here hey you don't have to
that was so embarrassing I'm gonna die
yeah that was really rough
let me make something clear
Jim and I have never and will never have
sex in the office
I'm gonna consider a romantic place
besides we have something those other
people don't have which is a home and a
bed
not a shower
all right